first of all I would like to thank the
organizers for giving for inviting me
and giving me the opportunity to give
this talk and generally I would say it's
a big privilege to be a participant of
this super interesting interdisciplinary
meeting here yes I'm used to make
forecasts and I also like to make a
forecast about the future of two
important or the two most important
vector ticks in Central Europe but I'm
used to make forecasts about some days
and this is a forecast about several
years it's much more difficult and much
more vague well let's see how it goes
well takes our worldwide distributed and
as blood feeling parasites on
terrestrial vertebrates they are
specially qualified to be vectors of
disease they are they cause high
economic loss in livestock farming and
also serious health problems in humans
in pet so they are major interest like
mosquitoes for example well we are here
in North America so it's perhaps quite
good to start with a slight well you
find some familiar things most of you
will be familiar with the main vector of
Lyme disease and the eastern United
States X cool XO the scapularis and
perhaps also with xodus pacificus an
important bridge vector of lambeau area
and the West these two tick species are
part of the subgenius xodus and the sub
genus hosts the most important vector
tix within the genius xodus in the north
and temperate zone of the world there's
also the so-called Tyga techniques or
spells okay toes and the area where I am
from from Europe it's Exodus treasonous
which is important and this I got this
slide from Jeremy grey and when I saw
this I
is really surprised how large the
distribution area of Exodus business is
for example in comparison with Exodia
scapularis and this also shows excellus
richness is present in different climate
zones in Europe but we don't know much
about the stick although it is by far
the best investigator take in Europe but
whenever you ask basic questions about
the ecology and also about the future of
that species in the next decades or even
centuries you will find gaps basic gaps
in our knowledge so I try my best to
collect the existing knowledge about
especially here about the life cycle and
well but there will be some question
marks that is clear at the end so exodus
richness is in central europe widely
distributed in common and approximately
8 to 10 million tick bites of this tick
occur per year in germany and we have 82
approximately eighty two million people
so it's quite a common problem in
germany to get a tick bite this tick
transmits borrelia burgdorferi causing
Lyme disease lamb Burroughs's and we
have every year approximately 50,000 to
100,000 new cases that's a lot more than
in the United States so we have a health
problem in this respect the problem in
Europe is is a bit different in one
respect at least from the United States
because we have different genomes
so-called genus species of borrelia
burgdorferi and some of them may be
human pathogenic others not so the
picture at the medical side I know it's
all so complicated here but it's also
very complicated in Europe and we have
another very important disease
tick-borne encephalitis caused by a
virus in Germany we have 200 + 500 cases
per year this does not sound very much
but if you get
the neurological part of the disease
it's a real severe disease there's no
treatment and but you can get
vaccinations but it's a severe disease
yeah there are other tick borne
pathogens transmitted by the sticks but
I will not go into any detail with this
now the second the second important
vector tick in Central Europe is demo
Center radiculitis you also have demo
center tick seared Emma Santa demo
center under Sonia the wood tick and
thermos entre variable is the American
dog tick but the life cycle the biology
is a bit different in Eurasian
dermacentor species well it is more and
more widely distributed and common
that's interesting also when we try to
look into the future of this stick but
own very rarely at least in Central
Europe people are bitten by the stick
the major issue is that it can transmit
a protozoan babesia kaneis kaneis this
cause this buck cause canyon bab EG OSIS
and this is a very dangerous disease for
dogs especially if you do not know what
the reason is well this is a rough life
cycle of heartaches of the family XO die
idee you generally have for development
for life stages you have three parasitic
life stages each of them needs a blood
meal and well that's the main point we
come back to this a bit later I will try
to discuss the possible or probable
future of these tick species coming from
the life cycle and i'm interested in
phases which are quite flexible flexible
means if conditions change they can
happen in a different season quicker
whatever and i'm looking for info
ssible faces the breaks in the life
cycle of these tix because it's very
easy to say when it's warmer tick
development will be quicker and quicker
and but this is very late person like
and as biologists we have another look
onto this I think so the main questions
are how do we saw this richness and demo
Center reticulatus organize their life
cycle what are the regulator faces in
their life how strong or how flexible is
their regular tough power what do we
know about their current distribution
and abundance how will they perform in a
warmer world and how will their
distribution and abundance be affected
by higher temperatures let's start with
derma Center this map from Germany shows
you the current distribution very
roughly and here you have the presumed
current northern limit of distribution
of Dharma Center reticulatus and twenty
years ago or twenty two years ago when
we tried to collect the stick we drove
to saxonia and and now the tick is in
Berlin unbelievable and it's also north
of Berlin but not much noise and so this
tick is just moving to the north so
we'll see how it may develop over the
next year's well distribution xodus
reasoner's I would say is boring because
in every county you will find xodus
reasoner's in Germany distribution
reasons there may be some mountains
uxorious reasoner's it does not occur in
at higher mountains that may be a task
for the future for xodus reasoner's and
there are very good studies from the
czech republic showing that it so does
reasoner's during the last 20 25 years
was able to climb some mountains to be
there and also to harbor some pathogens
there
well what are common habitats of Exodus
reason is in Central Europe it's mixed
forest with for example with beech trees
and Oaks and it's etches and beech trees
and oaks are very important factors for
the stick because the leaves the fallen
leaves of these trees will need for
being decomposed five to seven years
that's much longer than other deciduous
trees so where you have these trees you
will have a leaf litter which has
different generations of fallen leaf and
Exodus reasoner's likes high relative
humidity and such a big large or deep
layer of old Leafs is like a refugium
and it's easy for the tick to find just
the right relative humidity to survive
there it's follow Lant this during the
last during the past 20 years this was
quite common because the European Union
they sponsored that farmers stopped
working on some parts of the land to do
some agricultural work there and they
were paid for neglecting these areas and
these areas were super for ticks I can
tell you meadows are only good for the
stick if the conditions are humid enough
in areas where you have regular rainfall
or within forest meadows with in forests
and also places where you have a lot of
human traffic parks camping ground
cemeteries you can find xodus treasonous
but only in Berlin I can tell you
there's an inner city park the tea
garden and there were no tix in the late
70s and then they changed the management
that they let the old leaves in the
bushes in in the fall they didn't clear
them and ten years later they had a tick
problem there was no change
in the hospitai it was the only change
they did and that was a switch for xodus
treasonous to exist there well also
gardens gardens are very bad from from a
epidemiologic point of view because when
you have ticks in your garden infected
with borrelia it's very difficult to
protect yourself or your children or
whatever so a lot of cases of lyme
borreliosis occur in God's you will not
find xodus reasoner's in on dry meadows
and acreage agricultural fields so some
photos there's a typical mixed forest
also with some coniferous trees here
also and you see the closed and
permanent leaf litter this is a
coniferous forest it's if there is not
regularly rainfall it's not a popular
for xodus reasons but also there you
will find some accessories illness well
some some figures about the life cycle
one year ago or two years ago we would
have said the life cycle is two to four
years on average three years but we
found that the life cycle under natural
conditions is much longer and but I
cannot go into any details with this but
the longevity of a vector tick you can
easily imagine is very important if you
make some eco epidemiological analysis
you must know how long if does it take
how long can certain pathogens survive
in the vector tick well here again the
three parasitic life stages and if you
add up the the parasitic faces you come
up with two or three weeks but the whole
life cycle needs for 26 years it means
99% of the life cycle the tick will
spend free living well and there it is
it is a amongst various abbiati
conditions so to understand the life
cycle to understand the preferences and
tolerances of this tick we need to look
at the free-living stages
what are critical environmental factors
for the occurrence of Exodus reasoner's
well it's a habitat vegetation and the
vegetation to a large part they steer
the microclimate especially the humidity
so tick survival is touched from this
especially the office tick biology and
especially water balance of the tick a
very important factor is rainfall when
it rains then the leaf litter will keep
some water for several days and that's
as you know the place we are resting
uxorious reasoner's occur so it's not
only relative humidity as a rather
factor it's I would say it's much more
rainfall and the permanent leaf litter I
already mentioned in general it's
important for the stick as for many
arthropods terrestrial arthropods the
length of the growing season but in
Central Europe it's in the center of the
distribution of the stick this is not a
limiting factor only in mountains that
will be a factor and the lower threshold
is eight to ten percent of this develop
of the development this is not very
special what about winter temperatures
that's third of the year's winter more
or less and winter biology very often as
a neglected point in the biology of
organisms well and my partner at takada
hands total he worked many years on cold
hardiness and the winter biology of
Exodus racers and other tick species
everything what is deeper than minus 10
degrees Celsius the longer it and yours
the more dangerous is it for the tick it
is clear that takes neat hosts in
general I would say but this is not the
bottleneck of the life cycle within the
life cycle of Exodus reasoner's there's
one exception that's the host the host
for adult tix and the analytic is not a
Catholic feeder like the LA via nums but
it is
exclusively found on medium sized and
large mammals and that in some places is
limiting the abundance of Exodus
treasonous common reticulatus habitats
uxorious reasoner's is a wood tick in
principle with demo Center reticulatus
is not it likes open landscape mixed
mosaic like mixed landscapes lights
forest with clearings also the external
edges of forest grassland with bushes
follow length matters moorland and this
is a picture I couldn't have taken 25
years ago because there was a berlin
wall around West Berlin I come from
former West Berlin and I had one
wonderful habitat with a lot of Exodus
treasonous unfortunately I lost it with
a fall of the wall but well nevertheless
I'm a fan of the fall of the war and
this area now is free for for hikers for
walkers whatever joggers and here you
see a lot of grasses close to the forest
and in this border strip you will find
masses of Dharma Center reticulatus so
also that at least this takes species
benefits from the development around
former West Berlin what are the critical
factors for Dharma Center it's the
lengths of the growing season especially
the microclimatic summer temperatures
you will understand it better when i
come back in some minutes to this sonic
Oh sun exposure is a very important
factor it's not a wood tick as I said
but it loves exposed stands meadows
there comes more Sun and so development
is speeded up and this is quite
important availability of suitable host
it's a bit similar as with Exodus
business but here exclusively large
mammals wild boar Rodia red deer are the
typical hosts of Dharma Center
tickle our toes adult tix winter
temperatures in this case does not seem
very important it seems that the whole
derma Center in Eurasia more or less
comes from the east from mid Asia there
are several species for example in the
moon is built in Mongolia and when you
live in Mongolia as a tick you must be
very cold resistant because in such an
area day by day you have enormous
temperature oscillations and during the
night sometimes there is minus 20 and
over the day it's plus 10 or 12 and then
these tix Dharma Center natale not ready
colitis is active then so winter is not
a big issue well it's perhaps not easy
to understand that it is interesting to
know about the life cycle and the
seasonality of different events within
the life cycle in order to get a better
understanding of the vector role of a
certain tick and well but the seasonal
timing of the life cycle of a given tick
species in a certain region has critical
consequences for its suitability as a
vector of pathogens and for the peppered
duration of any microbial agents vector
by that tick species and I would like to
show this to you in the next slides
there's a slide showing xos reasoner's
and Dharma Center reticulatus the when
do these guys feat in different life
stages the egg is not feeding stage but
okay it's there if we start with Exodus
reason is it's a very simple story the
lava feeds from may to october you will
find active and feeding lavi on hosts
and it's not much different with the
nymphs and adults I start a bit earlier
and there may be a bit longer active in
the fall but nevertheless it's the same
and what appears here they are active
for a long time of the year at the same
time they will meet on the hosts and
this is very important for any kind of
transmission of take
borne pathogens different life stages
must meet that you can establish a
circle of transmission well when we look
at reticulatus it's completely different
and here let me start with the egg
although it's not a feeding stage it is
only there in early spring so the the
female whether it feeds in more in the
fall or in the late winter or spring it
lays its eggs in in spring and early
spring and the resultant larvae are you
will find only in May and June but you
will not find them because they're on
the nests of animals and they are not
long left in contrast to exodus
reasoner's they live without blood meal
six weeks at 15 degrees celsius then
they die but when you are in a nest you
have a good chance to find a host very
quickly they rapidly develop to the next
stage whenever they get a blood meal the
nymphs are on the host on July and
August also they are looking for a host
within nests well and they give rise in
the same growing season two adults so
this C sequence of events must be must
happen that Dharma Center reticulatus
can exist and now it's easier to
understand the warmer it is the easier
it is to to to make all these steps
within one growing season and when the
climate gets warmer it's clear that this
tech can more and more go to the north
because the conditions are favorable but
there's also these the lava and the
nymph they only meet in rare cases on
hosts and we know from EXO to scapularis
here in the North East it's great first
you have the names than the lobby so the
nymphs infect the host and the hose then
infect the larval stage in textbooks is
very nice
here it's just the other way around the
lobby says goodbye when the nymph
arrives so that's bad situation forget a
a transmission cycle of any tick borne
pathogens and if you and the adults are
on completely different hosts than the
level and the nymphal stage and they
feed more or less on other times of the
year so the adults does not meet feeding
larvae at mims nor in space nor in time
neta neither neither in time okay here
the primary way again very briefly of
xodus reason is born infections berea
booked a variety be virus usually
feeding them for some feeding nums are
infected they infect the host they the
host if it's a reservoir house or co
feeding host it passes on the infection
to feeding larvae these la vie developed
to nymphs and again if they are infected
these this is a very i would say simple
circulation with demo center it's more
complicated or more not so not so easy
to perform here it is that if you have
an in fact only and in this case it's
babesia kaneis is a tick borne pathogen
which I take as an example infected
adults infect the host and in turn other
feeding adults are infected and the
adult stage can live two years or even
longer so you can have different
generations of adult tix at the same
time so and these feeding adults they
transfer verily transmit the infection
to their offspring and then not the
lobby not the nymph only the next adult
of the f1 generation will again infect
the host so trans of Ariel transmission
is essential if demo center is a
maintenance vector of a given pathogen
so Dharma Center is not a maintenance
vector of TBE virus here turns over
our transmission is very rare as I say
it feeding adults do not need feeding
images and names seasonally follow the
lobby so that doesn't work well I also
saw in in one other talk conclusion in
question quite nice but they are close
together lifecycle suffix demo Center
reticulatus and Exodus reasoner's have
different very different season
allottees which has significant
consequences for the differential roles
as vectors and now the next question is
what are the regulating intrinsic and
extrinsic factors for each species and
will the duration of the lifecycle be
different with increasing temperatures
first I would like to clear two
different forms of dormancy dormancy
says it's a break it's a break in the
development or in the activity and there
are two distinctly different things or
patterns of dormancy one is so-called
quiescence this is a direct direction to
unfavorable external conditions for
example it's getting cold and the the
ticks in this case would react and go
down from the grass stems and wait until
the external conditions become favorable
n it's a direct reaction diapause is
genetically fix Thomas ii-induced before
the beginning of unfavorable conditions
for example when these tix uxorious
reasoner's enter diapause they do so as
early as in august because of the winter
but very early and this is genetically
fixed and induced by photo period this
is not the ultimate factor the factor
which makes us necessary for the tick to
rest but it's only the site gabar to
give the right timing and the reason for
entering diapause maybe the winter maybe
draw it whatever what about it derma
Center radiculitis there is also some
form of diapause in da mesentery
gelatos you will not find the adults
questing in the summer and as I already
mentioned engorged females do not
propose it when they are freshly fat in
the for although that with the
temperature it would be okay but they
don't even if you keep them in the
laboratory at 20 degrees Celsius they
don't lay any eggs and this starts only
in the next spring this is also a
process called seasonal gating and
seasonal gating is a very important
regulative process to coordinate the
whole life cycle with different seasons
well quiescence is this demo Center
adults are can be active in January can
be in December but they are not if it's
very cold if you have snow cover
whatever and this is a form of
quiescence because whenever it's mild
again these tix come out so dama Center
has a regulatory role only in the adult
stage but this seasonal pattern will be
most probably also very stable in a
warmer environment because you cannot
break diapause even with 20 degrees in
the winter and this the climate may be
much warmer in several decades but this
will not change well sorry for this
seemingly very complicated thing I would
say it's the message is not so
complicated here we are in it so this
treasonous they are forms or periods of
dormancy on the left hand side you have
the different life stages and when you
take a given life stage there are
different developmental phases within
one life stage and some of the life
stages are able to enter diapause so and
this i would call the breaks in the life
cycle whenever temperatures will be
higher these breaks will be as far as I
think will be
to prevent that the life cycle will get
shorter and shorter and there's some
evidence from the lab biology or lab
experiments with xodus treasonous you
can imagine there are many in many laps
there are transmission experiments and
so you infect a given laboratory host by
feeding nymphs then you put on it
negative on jnana if see no diagnostic
larvae and then you're waiting that this
scene or diagnostic la vie will develop
through the next stage and are hungry
again for the next black meal but this
is a time where you sit and cannot do
anything and the funding agency says
what about your results what about your
publications and you said well my tick
is not really hungry it needs some time
please for your understanding that's a
real problem when you have funning and
working with us so even and most of
these things I can tell you as
reasoner's failed failed completely the
head of a feeding success and of fifteen
or twenty percent they waited only four
or five or six months after the larval
blood meal and this is not exilis
reasoner's exodus reasoner's is a very
slow guy and so i'm really convinced
that the life the duration of the life
cycle and the seasonality of weeks or is
not will not change even if temperatures
are two degrees higher than now well
this is not very important this only
shows you when you feed ticks in the
spring or early summer no diapause 100%
direct development to the next
developmental stage and then in
mid-summer there's a switch and then
these engorge nymphs you have one
hundred percent diapause no direct
development these guys will overwinter
in the engorged state and only will malt
only in the next summer that's quite a
long time okay yeah
here some expectations concerning source
reasoner's what will happen if it's
warmer and I rely on the climate change
prediction for eastern Germany it's from
region to region the predictions are
really a bit different so i take this
region yeah and the prediction is that
the warmers will be warmer and drier and
that there will be more precipitation in
winter than now this is quite consistent
with a map that was shown a bit earlier
today well the winter in the winter if
the winter is more there you will find
more often occasional questing xodus
reasoner's and we found in the in the
winter of two thousand six to seven we
found regularly it the winter in berlin
was like in Marseilles so the winter in
Berlin was four point six degrees
Celsius on an average warmer than in
normal winter in Berlin and Exodus
treasonous nymphs and adults were
permanently active in January we
collected in two men hours more than 100
Exodus reasoner's this sometimes is not
so easy in May it was amazing we never
experienced something like this so this
can happen then if it's warmer or milder
in the spring the questing period may
begin earlier in summer it may be a bit
difficult because because of phases of
heat and draw it we'll see what happened
there and in the fall if it's warmer a
later end of the questing period we very
often sees this well but it take takes a
blood meal a black male has a certain
amount of energy and substance and it
take cannot be active forever and ever
although uxorious reasoner's we have
some cases from the engorged nymph
freshly and watched nums away from the
host until the final questing that may
need three years or or not it need is
not the right word that way may endure
three years at the tick without getting
another black meal can be questing and
is still full active and so on but it it
cannot always be busy we cannot always
be busy
it can also not be busy and if a tick is
busy in the winter it may be that the
energy is not enough to be active still
in the fall this is open we will see
what the tick can perform and this
changes from year to year i can tell you
even at the same location the pattern of
the seasonal activity changes very much
from year to year so weather has a clear
in fact and this is a question mark so
for the time being I don't think that
the duration of the life cycle will be
much short onyx oh this reason is in so
far there are different sorts of forests
in Central Europe where you can find
Exodus racers this I already say so I
can I think only one more point that
beech trees and oak oaks which are very
favorable for excellence reasoner's are
also favorable for take host populations
because they produce interesting things
you can eat as a mouse as a squirrel
whatever so there's also another
positive indirect in fact effect on the
tick populations so but the present for
is the mixed forest they will not stay
the same in Central Europe and that's a
very interesting series of papers by the
skirling at all we have for
approximately forty thirty five to forty
percent in Germany of the whole forest
is made by Bruce and pine trees and they
are at their limit they are north and
species and because of the glacier
period they came to the south and they
are still there because it's okay for
them but when we when we expect when we
expect a temperature increase of 2
degrees Celsius they will no longer be
productive and they will suffer and they
will decline however oaks and beech
trees will increase they will take this
and when we are talking ecology this
will be a process of hundreds or even
thousands of years but
most of the forest in Germany is
economic forest economically used forest
so the the character of the forest is up
to the forest owner he will decide what
will I plant in this kind of forest and
he knows this and who any knows that
spruce and pine trees will not give much
wood then he thinks what are the
alternatives and the alternatives there
are oaks and beech trees so this change
will be very rapid it will fall follow
equal economic laws and not ecological
laws well and this is clear that from
this dramatic change over the next
decades Exodus treasonous will increase
and also the abundance and XOR this
reasoning this bond disease will benefit
will increase from this and there's also
a point already now is we have a lot of
spruce forest pew pew spruce forest and
for ecological reason people are
changing this into mixed force also this
is a very good signal forex ODIs reason
is without that climate change so so
that change will dramatically increase
so what does it mean for the district
for all this for the future distribution
of Dharma Center reticulatus in Germany
well this is again the current presumed
north and distribution limit you can be
quite sure that demo Center reticulatus
will go closer to the Baltic Sea and the
North II it will increase its
distribution area again with Exodus
reasoner's it's not a topic distribution
is everywhere but it will climb a little
bit higher in the mountains and at the
end of my talk I will the year 2012 was
a very special year for xodus treasonous
and for excellence reason as researchers
be why it was a very low xodus
treasonous abundance in several
areas in Germany I could say many areas
but I'm better a bit cautious this was
based on counting of questing tick on
field plots what we did and flagging of
questing tix we did and also some other
researchers in Germany did so and there
was also a very low incidence of
tick-borne encephalitis I would call
this hard data because the the system
it's a notifiable disease and the system
is very reliable also a lower incidence
of human lambreaux uses this i would
call soft data because it's only in
parts of germany a notifiable disease
and well also notified case it cases
it's not so sure it's not so clear as
with stick bone encephalitis well some
briefly some data to give you the real
information I selected we have six
different tick locations where we
permanently work over the whole year and
I selected benefit and giessen and the
dotted curves are those from 2011 and
the normal curves are from 2012 the red
ones are adult Exodus reasoner's the
blue ones are nums all this were
observations on our field plots there is
no time to go into more detail with the
methodology if you ask me it's my
pleasure to answer this and you can I
think clearly see how much lower over
the whole year 2012 the seasonal
activity was in comparison to 2011 and
when you take the weather data from
these two places it yes we we were
speculating what was it and we didn't
find anything which was really
spectacular there was only one thing we
had a very cold and extreme cold spell
spell in Germany in january-february
2012 and here this line will show you
the maximum temperature so the
temperature did not
go over zero degrees Celsius for more
than two weeks the dotted line is the
minimum temperature 5 centimeter above
the ground where X or services more or
less is and you can see it goes up to
minus 15 or in some cases up down to
minus 20 degrees Celsius which is
clearly bad news for excellence
reasoner's well XO this reasoner's
occurs in scandinavia well what's the
problem with these temperatures well in
Scandinavia normally you have snow cover
a big snow cover during the winter and
what about the snow cover here you can
see here the scale approximately less
than 1 centimeter and for a long time
nothing and here the same and snow has a
clearly buffering effect if you measure
in the winter in the winter night
especially temperature just above the
snow cover and below the snow cover you
will end up with much lower temperatures
above the snow cover and at the moment
this is our working hypothesis that this
was responsible for this this unusual
cold spell in the winter in combination
with the missing or very thin sit snow
cover in many areas had as far as we
think at the moment strong effect on the
survival of ticks also on the physical
of their physiological condition and
therefore also on the overall level of
questing on the subsequent vegetation
period we have tix on in our field plots
which were put out as a gorge names in
the fall of two thousand eleven and
these tix will be active in 2013 and so
I am a bit optimistic to say we might
obtain some more conclusive data on this
in 2013 because it's all it takes mold
in the summer those tix from the autumn
2011 they experience the cold whereas it
takes which were put out in early summer
2012 they didn't experience the cold so
I would
expect if we are right with our
hypothesis that those tix put out in
early summer 2012 they do very well they
are very active if nothing bad happens
this winter but the tix which we have
put out in the fall 2011 they will have
very bad performance well this here the
the figures of the TBE cases you have
the last three the past three years give
the average of ten years and here of the
poor results from 2012 and also lam
Berlioz's cases sixty percent of the
cases in 2011 that also shows if you
it's not a proof it's also human
behavior we all know this but it's a
strong indication that when you're
working on vectors and on vector ecology
and you find really clear trends that
this might also be very indicative of
what's going on with the tick-borne
diseases okay final consideration a
warmer climate and Central Europe might
increase the abundance of Exodus
reasoner's this is an indirect indirect
effect of the vegetation it might extend
the distribution area of Dharma Center
reticulatus at its northern border and
it might not strongly affect the
seasonal timing and the length of the
life cycles of Exodus reasoner's nor
dermacentor reticulatus and one point
which is hard to define when we are
talking about vector ecology we should
also and climate and weather we should
also have a look at the occurrence of
extreme weather spells in the future in
our consideration because they will from
time to time will have a strong strong
impact on the well-being of these vector
tick populations and all this sounds
very concrete I'm well aware that there
are major gaps in our knowledge and so
it's clear that much more research is
needed very often on very basic
questions and I only talk to
Central Europe in England there was Sir
Randolph she has also built very nice
models but in other parts of Europe we
don't know anything about the life cycle
and this is I think demanding to do so
there are there are many people in the
field which do the work I do not present
many of the results we are grateful for
the support from the german ministry of
the environment for collecting data and
yes thank you very much for your kind
attention